[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh rick stroud covers the buccaneers for
the tampa bay times he's got a great gig
there's always something going on with
the tampa bay buccaneers and rick kind
enough to join us
rick how's morale today in tampa
um it's good i guess i mean unless
you're tom brady maybe you're a little
depressed but uh you know look
overall this
we all kind of knew how this would end
right maybe not ripping your clothes off
you know to your to your waist but we we
did know that at some point antonio
brown um was going to have a meltdown
and it was sad to see on national
television but um you know this this
seemed to be inevitable to me
i just don't understand tom's saying yes
need we need to show compassion he needs
help did he need help prior to what
happened on sunday rick we've we've
covered we're enablers here let's not
let's not dance around this we're
enablers
i i you're a 100 right and tom brady is
the guy that stuck his neck out and said
no i i want this guy here i care about
him you know he's coming off the
eight-game suspension last year um you
know we heard about anger management and
tony robbins is he's a changed guy and
he moves him into his house so i mean
tom as much as anybody if he was worried
about his mental health i don't think
putting a guy on a football field um you
know is the way to do it he was there
because he could still make plays and
and you know
that's the only reason and we are we're
all sort of enablers in that in that
sense and and you know he's had this
pattern for the last three or four years
he wears out his welcome in pittsburgh
you know i'm not loved here i want to go
to the raiders and then i get in a fight
under my helmet in it you know now i'm
going to go someplace else and he was
you know great last year for for a
little while and and now we have this
situation so i don't i don't know about
the mental health aspect of this i'm not
i'm not in that field um i i just know
that there's a lot of words to describe
antonio brown you know and i've heard
them all he's a narcissist selfish
destructive
um you know a bully at times i mean
there's there's lots of words to
describe him uh and i and i just think
that
you know playing him right now if you're
truly worried about his mental health
that's that's probably not the best
place for him to be i also wonder about
the strategy when i realized that you
know you had bruce erin saying he's not
a buccaneer anymore and i went well i
don't know if he's technically not a
buccaneer officially not a buccaneer but
if you're looking at salary cap you're
looking at could he potentially play for
somebody else in the postseason so
what what exactly is happening with the
buccaneers and antonio brown
well they're consulting with the
national football league about their
options about what procedures they can
actually use if it was as simple as hey
we don't want him on our team we're
releasing him that could have happened
yesterday and it didn't okay and and i
suspect the reason it didn't happen is
because because we're past the trade
deadline he's subject to waivers and he
could wind up on a playoff team playing
against them and it's kind of ironic
right you don't want the guy but you
don't want him to beat you um so you
know there's going to be a grievance
here you they the bucks can feel it
that's why bruce arians isn't saying a
lot about the conversation he had on the
sideline abs camp is saying that he was
injured that he didn't want to go back
in the game because of his ankle um
that's not really what bruce arians is
subscribing to so but what he did after
that fact the fact that he you know they
didn't put him back in the game but his
antics on the field taking off his
uniform running through the end zone
leaving the stadium that's conduct
detrimental okay and i suspect that
that's probably where they'll fall maybe
they can put them on some suspended list
maybe not pay him that's up to them um
but my guess is if they wanted to just
get rid of him and release him and make
him available to the rest of the nfl
that would have happened by now
it's it doesn't help his argument when
he's dancing in the end zone claiming
that he has an injured angle here rick
yeah he's doing jumping jacks and you
know throwing things to the fans and
yeah all of that and i mean and even now
right like he's he's still stuck in new
york for all i know it's it's like home
alone they left kevin or something you
know he's at the brooklyn nets game it's
like you know uh i'm not sure he's had a
change of clothes i mean i i don't know
what what's going on but uh yeah if he
was that injured i'm with you he seemed
to be running pretty well up until the
point where he didn't go back into the
game and it didn't stop him on the way
out of the stadium bigger picture here
the buccaneers going into the postseason
last year they had a ton of momentum
they were healthy everything was you
know ahead of schedule here uh
handicapped the buccaneers now as they
got one more regular season game
well they're pretty handicapped
offensively and now they got uh injuries
again on the defense i mean both jason
pierre paul shaq barrett who's a big
piece of what they do on defense levante
david uh those two guys barrett and
david will probably come back but to
what degree how how effective they'll be
we don't know um you know look i would
say this that and bruce arian said it as
long as you have tom brady he just has a
way of figuring out the puzzle right
they have other options um you know they
still have three tight ends ronkowski
has played well if he can stay healthy
they've got cam break in the red zone oj
howard we haven't seen most of the
season but we know he can be a problem
for some teams this cyril grayson has
been one of the best stories in the nfl
guy that didn't play college football
because he ran track at lsu now making
all these plays they still have richard
perriman scotty miller we haven't seen
we remember the big plays he made so i
would not say that they don't have any
playmakers leonard fournette may come
back let's see if they can get all this
together um they're continuing to build
some momentum i think and uh they got a
couple weeks to figure it out if they
can get a home game or two uh again i it
would not surprise me if you saw tom
back in the championship game it's
assumed that he's brady is back next
year in tampa correct
uh i guess
i don't know i mean he's under contract
right he he did this thing but he can
get out of it it's there's not like a a
ton of cap you know penalties if he
doesn't play um two things will decide
it and and one is how does he feel
health-wise and he said unless he
suffers some injury um he thinks he can
play till he's 50. the biggest thing is
just his family you know what and
giselle says every year if you had
enough
and but the reality is is that he's got
three kids now that are of the age where
they're doing things um you know outside
of the of the home and and they have
sacrificed a lot for him but i can't see
him playing more than one more year dan
i think 45 for whatever reason seems to
be a weird number that's stuck in his
head um does he walk away if they win
and and and but he could win three in a
row and no one's done that um does if
they get to the championship and he
thinks they can win again next year
it's hard to it's hard to really fathom
but like i know this about the greatest
players in sport they seem to be the
ones that don't know when to leave the
party right like the vacuum cleaners are
going the lights are on they're still
there man they're still at the bar so i
don't know what what tom brady will do
but i think he'll be back next year i
was on a town hall zoom call with him
with some other
media members and i said to him about
that
moment that i had when i left espn and
part of the reason was i was going to
miss out on my kids you know i have
three daughters and my oldest is a son
and my wife said they're going to be all
out of the house
and i was turning 50 and i said to tom
you know are you worried that you're
going to wake up one day and the kids
are going to be out of the house
and and it got him emotional like he
because i
it's there
and i think gisele saying a couple years
ago about how tom has had concussions
nobody had ever talked about tom having
concussions but it feels like it's that
tug of war there of
i want to continue to play
and
but then your kids kind of go on without
you and then you try to get you dive
back into their lives and you could tell
where
he's gonna have that tug of war
you know if he decides to play a couple
more years
yeah i think he's having it right now as
a father i understand that i i do think
though um you know at least with respect
to his oldest son he had him in training
camp last year he's been down a number
of times for practice um you know those
kids are also old enough to appreciate
and enjoy his career um you know so i'm
not going to say hey dad you know let's
go win another super bowl and and it's
okay if you miss all my basketball games
but they know it's at the end too and i
think they know how much it means to him
he said something that when he got the
sports illustrated man of the year award
that resonated with me he said i have to
be comfortable sitting on the couch
watching other guys play on a sunday
going i know i'm better than that
you know what i mean and he's going to
be better than three-fourths of them at
age 45. so that's the toughest thing man
is that he knows he can still do it
rick great to talk to you we'll talk to
you soon thank you again
that's rick stroud covers the buccaneers
for the tampa bay times host of sports
day tampa bay podcast as well